here's clayton kershaw making his sixth
start of the season
and another one here at dodger stadium
where he is second all-time in wins with
95
and second all time and strikeouts both
those behind don
sutton and off to a very strong start is
responding to a tough outing in his last
one
but loves the pitch here at dodger
stadium nick senzel
climbs in that is scalded through the
left side hole base hit nick senzel
on and nobody out jesse winker homer in
three consecutive games
he's got a hit and 12 straight that's
the longest streak in baseball
runner goes throw down from barnes not
in time
safe slide as sinzell barely hangs on
does the superman there off the back
immediately putting pressure on kershaw
runner in scoring position
is this ball's floated the left into
that bright sunshine for aj pollock in
the first out of the day
one on one out here's nick castiano's
first shot of castillanos with an o2
senzelle runs again swinging a miss and
he's out at third
to end the inning strike him out throw
him out the reds who steal less than any
team in baseball getting aggressive here
in the first inning
and barnes ensuring that the inning
comes to an end 31 year old sonny gray
makes his third start start of the
season delayed he had some back spasms
during spring training
and he's struggling to get going couple
of starts seven
runs allowed in eight innings pitch
mookie bets six for his last 34
an unusual stretch for bats so he gets
set to face
sonny gray is one two smackdown
[Applause]
runner in scoring position nobody out
gavin likes the battery gallo right
castellanos makes the grab
justin turner will take his turn at the
plate
fastball lovato
makes the catch immediate pivot bet
stays at second
that'll bring up max muncie swing and a
miss ball briefly lost stevenson gathers
put out complete a nice job by sonny
gray to work around the double from vets
joey botto to lead off against clayton
kershaw
kershaw gets him with a good slider in
his second k
dodgers with runners at the corners and
nobody out luke
raleigh a chance to get the dodgers on
the board on the first pitch from gray
it's a ground ball to second they will
turn two but a run comes through the
back door and it's one nothing
as taylor steps out you did not retire
the opposing pitcher
after your head one ball and two strikes
you wind up walking
sunny gray sendzell gets a hit
the pitch count continues to mount and
opportunities
really come for the other ball club and
keep in mind the reds are the best
hitting team
in baseball with runners in scoring
position coming in today's game
and they've got the best hitter on the
best hitting team at the plate right now
and jesse winker 2-2
ground ball up the middle gavin luck's
second start of the season it's short
wide throw but muncie's got it and the
side is retired
sonny gray back out to the hill his
third inning of work he will get the top
of the dodger order
3-2 pitch strength three called he got
it that time
third k for sonny gray now gavin lux
comes up
strike three back to back hayes for gray
as he starts his second time through
look at the run the backwards run on
that pitch
i mean how does the hitter adjust to
that gray struck out three in a row now
it's turner with the bases empty and two
out
turtle smashes the ball way up there way
back
and gone justin turner with home run
number
six and the dodgers lead it two nothing
boy put a charge into that one
face it for bottle with one out puts him
at first base now three of the four
innings here in the early going that the
reds have had a runner
here's a eugenio suarez ground ball
toward third diving stop by turner
to his feet throws to first in time to
get suarez
what a play by turner he laid out to his
glove side left
popped up and made a tremendous throw
gray
who's allowed three hits has struck out
five after sonny gray really got rolling
i think
was looking the best that he's looked at
any point this year
swing at a miss nice pitch from gray
he's got six strikeouts
he's with five of the last six dodgers
swing and a miss
curveball way outside to pollock but he
offered at it he is down on strike
seven for sonny gray now strike three
gray has eight strikeouts today the last
seven outs that have been made in this
game by the dodgers have all
been by way of the strikeout swing and a
miss struck him out with a curve ball
in the dirt bet strikes out for the
second time today
make it nine k's for sonny gray front
door fastball
that's what it is right over the inside
corner strike three called ten
punch outs for sonny gray as he strikes
out gavin lux
to close out a one two three dodger
fifth golf man aboard tying right at the
plate in the form of jesse winker
then he went around kershaw strikes out
winker
sixth one for kershaw no two from
kershaw he swings and misses and a
slider
back-to-back caves against two of the
top hitters in the league for kershaw
not out of the woods yet
another guy with enough power to tie the
game and joey vado
digs it out and a bounce right side
that's the inning
sunny gray his 10th career double digit
strikeout game
he's had six backward case today tying a
career high
did he go turner started he went and
that's 11 strikeouts for
sunny gray this afternoon against the
dodgers
gray's day is done but a dynamite one
for sonny gray one off his career high
he leaves with 11 strikeouts
hendricks comes out of the bullpen walks
the first man and now the dodgers with
two on and two out for luke raley
breaking ball chopped mustache surveys
long throw otto stays on the bag
the inning is over clayton kershaw has
been in command from the start of this
one
kershaw trying to get through seven
shutout innings got him
swinging eight strikeouts for clayton
kershaw there's seven shutout innings
[Music]
first and third one gone and jesse
winker coming out trying to extend the
12-game hitting streak another one-two
he's [ __ ] out disappearing slider
from trinidad
number two two gone in the eighth inning
nick castianos
at the whole game and they'd like to add
on if possible here
two outs with two out for taylor swung
on and driven to right
back on it goes castellanos he is to the
track it's over his head
and off the wall turner's gonna get
waved around
third much needed insurance three
nothing
now it's pollock to left center field
debris home taylor
two-out flurry doubles their scoring
output for the day
four nothing man baby has the pitch
hitter
slice the left that is
[Applause]
the dodgers had two more it's six
nothing they get bets to the plate one
more time
an explosion for the dodgers here in the
eighth
it's eight nothing that's down to their
final out
order being restored today there it is
that does it the dodgers get back to
their winning ways behind
seven shutout innings from clayton
kershaw